hey y'all it's Monday xxx 2020 we're in
the apocalypse research and Stevens to
go for the Steven Seagal show yeah I
think yeah I think I'm gonna bump that
up in the schedule just because it seems
like well it's like you know he's a
terrible person okay let's just say that
right let's not go that far let's like
this listen let's not go that far let's
not be negative like that let's give the
man a fair shake let's finish the
investigation
I'm just saying make the analysis when
he's got when time comes there have been
many allegations many of these
allegations are probably true he was a
man of his time no not real that's no
it's not really it was not a man of his
time no I'm just saying that I what I
was gonna say where I was going with
that was that you know we do so many
shows about horrible serial killers and
everything like that so I just thought
this even though Steven Seagal is not
really that great of a person apparently
um it will still be a lot more fun at
least at least you didn't chop people up
and eat them you know that we know of
I'm looking at this is like a paranormal
episode okay okay because it's more like
paranormal to me paranormal episode you
know if I can you know what there are
paranormal claims in martial arts
oriental martial arts as is making
paranormal claims a lot some some
disciplines do yeah which we talked I
don't think Aikido could work I don't
give a [ __ ] what this guy says Aikido
itself is a parent role I read some
really fascinating stuff today that I
that I didn't know about him that was
really funny no I don't know if it's
yeah I'm not gonna say I'm gonna say it
I'm just saying that that's what I've
been doing this morning is just I've
been reading about Steven Seagal and
also I must say that oh and speaking of
serial killers Marcos I think just sent
me a Facebook message and said that
remember that serial killer we did a
show about in the Grim Sleeper and he
killed like a whole [ __ ] ton of people
like it I think it was in LA yeah he
died he was in
I think he died today or yesterday okay
so I just got the message today dude
yeah pretty much
we might so I don't know I might have to
like go and revisit that case but we did
do a show about him a while back I also
want to say that somebody where did I
see it I saw it on Instagram or so no
somebody's video or something like that
I know probably everybody's sick of like
super fed Dmitry posted on Facebook
today he's like I'm so sick of hearing
about Tiger king yeah yeah Markus is all
in Turkey - I told you Marcus idea oh
the memes are so good that was my
favorite one that I've seen it or not
it's like a shot from it with you know
Joe exotic and like the Tigers and the
American flag and everything and that it
says this is the genie that comes out
when you rub a two liter of Mountain Dew
yeah that's a good internet right there
golden nugget memes go around everywhere
that was my turning point Mike as soon
as I saw that scene go down I Jenni is
my witness I jumped up back you just
gotta buddies are walking around a
circle shaking my head and I'm there
showing the family and [ __ ] that was
sitting in the front that front pew you
know I mean and their reactions I could
just see the [ __ ] hatred coming out
of their eyes that one yeah that was
like and I know we got we got one
subscribe yeah i'm friend of josie he's
a nice guy and i'm just goes no well I'm
just saying that not any problems there
brah I think he started out as a nice
guy but like I said kind of everybody
that's not what it involved into ever
just on the back just on the back of the
chimps are the chimpanzees - should have
looked them chimps out I forgot about
that I was like reading another along
here and I mean at least he had the
decency to be like self-awareness oh
well I should have liked it let them be
to become like yeah yeah
if you know about animals and if they
reaching out through the bars because
these are very social yeah you know what
I mean you can't just lock them up by
themselves like that they'll go crazy
they're part human
well there's 98.5
or something like yeah you know manimals
there was it that was a TV TV show in
the 70s cancer some [ __ ] like it I don't
remember much about it I said mostly I
don't remember the show I remember like
MST making some jokes about it yeah
because they were super intellect
against candy ripoff was it I think so
I thought it was before Thundercats
knows maybe maybe Thundercats was was it
like a guy that could hurt was he a
shapeshifter
I don't remember I think it was several
of them I don't even know if I'd known
it was that this show was gonna go this
direction that were Wikipedia that [ __ ]
that was specifically targeted to the
eight year old mind of a boy that's a
badass [ __ ] the man turns into a noise
am animal you know I guarantee you a
head
it had werewolves and and my hats bare
my head [ __ ] dinosaurs and robots and
we're one band then robotic dinosaurs
you know which boys [ __ ] that's awesome
yeah yeah watch that yeah missile
missiles on the dinosaurs Jets on the
dinosaurs everything see that sounds rad
yeah if they made that now I would watch
it I'd be all into that [ __ ] when I was
fifteen I know yeah man it's got Jets on
it you know [ __ ] turret pterodactyl
with Jetson yeah I was super into
dinosaurs yeah and machine guns Conan I
know all the names of like all the Latin
names and everything I was a total nerd
what did you want to talk about is that
it um I think so I was just talking
about like Steven Seagal I think I was
talking about that [ __ ] yeah I'm
trying to prepare everybody mentally for
the [ __ ] changes that are to come the
acceleration ISM and one of the things
that I've been studying recently is the
effects of pandemic on Hollywood
Hollywood is losing its [ __ ] mind
it's [ __ ] falling apart the theater
systems are [ __ ] up just it's I don't
think it's going to survive and in the
way that you remember one of the things
that just happened is that some of these
evidently some of these studios who made
these movies Seth [ __ ] they're
releasing them right to streaming so
yeah so but the thing is it's like
that's bypassing that's bypassing key
player
in that system you know I mean so that
means certain dinosaurs are gonna go
extinct because they're gonna find out
that's gonna be a more efficient way of
selling a movie because the the the
business model of a lot of the state
said that they do of the studio model is
not efficient
that's why Netflix is kicking its ass ya
know so you're gonna see a lot of stuff
vanished including I predict just on the
back of the studio
Hollywood traditional studio Hollywood
system falling apart
I think there's additional studio
Hollywood movie star will fall apart
there's no reason to pay them all that
money and a lot of it is that they
people are pointing now you know these
these the reason why a lot of these
movies fail is because of social media
these stars get on social media and make
an ass out of themselves and then people
don't want to see the damn movie they
don't like them anymore so they're so
you the star itself the movie star is
becoming detrimental to a movies success
so it's almost gonna be like it's better
to put a nobody in there because if you
look at Netflix most of the cast or
people you'd never recognize they're not
movie stars they're not from the
generation that you know well I mean a
lot of them are actors and they're in a
bunch of stuff like I'd recognize there
a TV show right but it's like they
probably wouldn't get recognized by
night yeah and they're not making a
movie star paychecks
yet I mean they're just a kind of
marking act they're a working stiff like
everybody else yeah I mean when you
start getting into that damn movie star
realm it looks like that's backfiring
that's not a good marketing technique
anymore so I predict the end of the
movie star well I don't know yeah I feel
like it's kind of been going like that
for a while why would you hire one thing
you're just gonna ruin your movie just
because I mean I feel like and we
probably discussed this before but I
kind of feel like everything you know
the the coming of the internet you know
with all the technology being so cheap
and people being able to make their own
movies for like a tiny tiny fraction of
the cost that you know that they used to
cost and it does seem like everything is
going more like democratized yeah and
there are so many more options for
people like independent filmmakers to
get their [ __ ] out there for like people
to see and it's
yes there's a glut of stuff most of the
stuff is probably pretty bad but you
know I I do think that there's better
movies and I've seen I'm not [ __ ] on
like you know big-budget holidays I've
seen some good ones like recently and in
the past few years and stuff but I do
feel like it's gonna go the way of just
smaller yeah Studios like making yeah
movies that they wanted to make for much
less money right with a smaller audience
but that actually goes to it right it's
a smaller niche right type of things
which I think that's been going on and
be a lot better and you know like I said
that's that's kind of one of the best
things about the Internet is that you
can find exactly what you want and you
can find like a few thousand other
people that are into the exact same [ __ ]
as you and you know what I mean in some
ways you know you can boom own the loss
of like oh when everybody had the same
TV channels and everybody talked about
the same TV shows and everybody because
now everything's really fractured and
stuff in that time that time was not
cool
but yeah it's like it's really I don't
really miss that where everybody was
like talking about the same cuz you
didn't really have that many options and
we ended up not not being able to watch
television it wasn't made for us
yeah that's what I mean because I I felt
flushed new that was like kind of like
isolating because like a lot of the
popular TV shows like when I was growing
up like in the 70s and 80s I wasn't
really into them I was into like you
know more weird [ __ ] yeah and there and
it was harder to find other people that
were into that it was harder to find was
weird
NUI be off back there well it was it was
to be into like weird music it was hard
to be into weird movies it was just like
harder to find everything especially
where I grew up that you know it wasn't
like a real was around so you had to
like order everything to the mail and it
was like a big giant pain so I don't
really miss that kind of like oh we all
like watch the same stuff it's like I
would rather it just be even even if you
know one show that you like doesn't get
like hugely famous or doesn't make like
millions and zillions of dollars
it's like at least it has like a
hardcore base yeah of you know a million
fans or something like that and that's
exactly what they like and I predict the
the actors of the future in these future
movies and a lot of a lot of them
this is what I'm talking about is
happening now they're gonna be kind of
like working stiff actress and they're
gonna be under order you can't go on
social media and run your [ __ ] mouth
because it ruins movies that's what they
used to do back in the old city they
used to keep everyone did keep everybody
[ __ ] under brats right Wow for a while
it seemed like Hollywood would send
their [ __ ] actors out there to go out
there and you know I mean run their
mouths and grandstand in it and I guess
that generated ticket sales but it
doesn't anymore I think public's kind of
turned against it I mean you know the
good example brie Larson brie Larson ran
her mouth and [ __ ] movie started not
doing that well you know just it just
see people can only put up with your
[ __ ] for a certain amount of time well
I'm not it's not the 1980s anymore and
the thing too is that I mean it depends
on what kind of movie but if you're
making like just a fun popcorn you know
superhero movie let's say yeah people
want to go see that like it to turn
their brain off like an escapist and if
you like attach all these other things
to it you should then people are gonna
like get kind of soured and exhale like
man I didn't really want to think about
that like gonna see me even if they
agree with her yeah um you know it's
like I didn't really want to think about
I just wanted to go see a fun [ __ ]
movie show how today you know that's
what happened to birds of prey they sent
them set the mattress out there to talk
[ __ ] to grandstand behind that movie and
going all the you know
this is a woman's movie then the men are
gonna hate it they didn't go see it I
shouldn't have done that what was his
name got played obi-wan Leah McGregor I
like the guy but they gave him orders to
go out there and [ __ ] say crazy [ __ ]
about the movie which pulled the legs
out money at the movie it's like you
know what the movie was pretty good well
yeah that's what I'm you know because I
didn't get that sense from the movies
like that is like oh this is not a movie
for men yeah yeah then maybe wasn't like
that it was just like a normal movie
from the 9th from the 90s yeah I didn't
I didn't like the Camaro or some steam I
didn't get that message for the me
neither I mean um you know they went out
and tried to sell that movie as having
some kind of a Pro feminist [ __ ]
political message and I didn't see any
political message I mean and I'd like I
said I would concern myself with them
I agree with some of this [ __ ] that they
said but it's like I don't know one you
don't have to attach the movie and to
though it wasn't what the movie was
about yeah was just like a fun it was
just a function movie action movie I
mean was that you'd have to really
really stretch to like so any kind of
like political it was an anti man or not
at all I didn't find it answer it was
just a silly feel-good action movies
like semi comedy I feel like maybe maybe
people nowadays have gotten so [ __ ]
highly strong that they think any movie
that just has a bunch of women in it is
automatically anytime man I don't think
so I don't think was it not at all I
think what it was is it was just a
normal movie that was pretty good and
they hired an Abba there I tried to stir
up controversy ya hired an advertising
agency and they thought they stirred up
a bunch of controversy about it it would
get a bunch of asses in the seats nobody
saw it sometimes that works
Nonnie well a lot of times it blows up
in your face blew up and then that just
goes to show you that these big
Hollywood studios are hiring people that
are very detached from reality and
they're actually destroying the products
that they make they should just release
the [ __ ] just let it go naturally yeah
don't say anything about it I mean Jenny
been a better day to make more money hit
the aside said nothing about the [ __ ]
movie
well yeah because then people would have
seen it and been like hey yeah made
their own conclusions it was I don't
need to be hiring these [ __ ]
promotional
companies to hire it too well like I
said I make that you make you make the
[ __ ] what do you call it thing you
make the trailer and then you shut the
[ __ ] up I think like I said I think
people are trying to I mean I'm not
gonna say that outrage doesn't sell
because it does it gets attention is hit
and miss though but yeah you never know
it might work it might not and in a lot
of ways I think more studios because
there's so much money on the line
they're willing to take the risk just
because they want the attention
yeah but sometimes it it kind of like
you know there's a backlash yeah but I
do see where they're coming from because
they are right in saying that like
outrage gets clicks it gets attention it
does negative [ __ ] gets attention more
than
positive [ __ ] does look at these
probably spent millions or tens of
millions of dollars they probably gave
to that company to promote that thing
and they botched it yeah they saved that
tens of millions of dollars and just put
a damn trailer out there you'd have had
a neutral audience and it probably would
have not only would they save the money
on promotional fees they would have
probably done better at the box office
I think about birds of prey is that they
all shine Idol was [ __ ] up
they also shouldn't have paid the person
who made the first trailer because the
second trailer was much better yeah like
the first trailer I was like that was
kind of dumb looks doesn't like the
second one I was like oh that's much
better now it actually looks like second
trailer we better and who ever titled
that movie was [ __ ] insane
yeah Harley Quinn yeah and then you
could have put like Harley Quinn Fabray
or something like that
yeah because and a lot of people said
that just because you know the birds of
prey were in it but not really until the
end when they all teamed up and stuff so
I what seemed that actress she was the
one Fargo Robbie yes she was she was in
170 yeah she played Sharon Tate I think
she did a great job in it well and she
clearly loves playing that character I
did not like I said I didn't see Suicide
Squad so I don't know because a lot of I
think a lot of people [ __ ] on theirs
just it was just a shame now I think
maybe they should have gone for an
alternate um Harley Quinn look I think
she should have been cuz there's a bunch
of different ways she was drawn like you
said more Tank Girl look more Tank Girl
more punk-rock looking I think she I
think it would have looked better to
know some people oh you were going for
that male gaze male gaze puts [ __ ]
asses in seats you don't have to go that
way but what is male gaze it just means
what is attractive you know man it's
just semi-nude attractive I'm not
necessarily saying that but what if she
was like look at cat Catwoman the
Michelle Pfeiffer's Kevin she wasn't
hardly everyone
she wasn't even hardly even shown any
skin yeah yet I mean but have a sexy
yeah you know and there was a lot of
Harley Quinn costumes that were like
along that same lines they should have
gone that way little darker a little
more edgy you know yeah she looked a
little frumpy in that frilly [ __ ]
thing that they had are in yeah the
feather you think I feel
they were doing like I liked some of the
costumes but yeah I can see she has a
nice figure that she you know I mean
they should have [ __ ] you know not
really showcased it but just not
concealed it yeah I should have put her
in something a little more sleek yeah I
mean like a Catwoman type outfit I
thought it would been a lot better that
red and black one with the [ __ ]
little the Harlequin outfit yeah
although I get that she was trying like
the kind of the premise of the movie was
she was trying to distance herself
remember and I should have gone for more
than tank girl look and it's like they
it's almost coming they didn't were
afraid to mention the existence of the
Tank Girl movie because it was it was a
very similar they now I I will say that
I haven't seen Tank Girl in a really
long time but I remember really really
like it's like I think it's bad but it's
like eyes a comment but movie of it yeah
of the day which you see these veiny it
took a long time to get those right yeah
cuz they've made like a lot of
comic-book movies over the years yeah
like back in the 80s and stuff like that
and a lot of them were really really
terrible the tone of Tank Girl was kind
of I it was weird
yeah is for some reason I always tank
girl was the original Gwen Stefani yeah
in a way yeah definitely you know no
that's well that yeah as soon as I saw
as soon as no doubt like got pop yes
like I was like hey tank girl looks like
Lori petti attacker yeah it does yeah
anything else you wanted to know yes on
this Monday daily whatever you call it
all right so we're gonna oh we actually
did go to the liquor store yesterday
yeah and um it was like one other person
in there it didn't touch Ted handle when
I opened up the door and afterwards
outside
oh no and he drove home with his hand
like that Oh bleeped White City but he's
wiping down the bottles and [ __ ] well
all they were doing cuz like that with
the public's we just went to we actually
ended up not going to Sam's cousin oh
it's a lot farther it's like three or
four miles away
whereas public's is just right there and
um they have a liquor store so I said
well they're probably open I think the
only thing cuz Publix is full look like
the parking lot was full the liquor
store there's only one or two other
people in there but um because you know
those are the people that have the
correct priorities but I think all they
were doing was that they were closing
early because I think normally they
would close at 9:00 or 10:00 but they
were
closing at 8 p.m. to do like extra like
cleaning of the store like everything
was being like decontaminated like every
evening turns out I saw some data man
all the rich people are running from New
York and are coming down here to hide
from the damn plague in there some and
they're probably bringing all they're
bringing all that [ __ ] cooties down
it's off understand understand you don't
want to be [ __ ] you know locked up
with that [ __ ] inside that damn City
when they all start getting sick and
going crazy you know rich people are all
running but once you stand there even if
you're sick at least you're here they
can be sick in isolation yeah I'm and
they won't spread it but once you guys
heal up [ __ ] out of here you back up in
New York well it oh yeah I did that I'm
telling them all to go back [ __ ] out
here go over New York well it's that
like at least they have money to like go
somewhere like most people don't
yeah and they're just kinda like stuck
where they are [ __ ] yeah so I was
sick with a mother New Yorkers come out
here telling us what to do that with the
other rich people yeah go make each
other yeah we're not doing to the bad
we're not rich people but nobody they're
just I don't want to make it class
warfare just more about man every time I
get into a fight with some do some old
dude from New York [ __ ] at Starbucks
trying to tell me you know what to do oh
well we you guys shouldn't be riding
those motorcycles because it's us it's
us that has to pay for your medical
injuries may get the [ __ ] out of here do
nearly get I didn't tell you about that
one did you
yeah yeah it has the years back it
almost got his ass beat saying that [ __ ]
from a bunch of [ __ ] motorcycle 70
and and he said that to a bunch of
[ __ ] dudes didn't get well old people
don't know when to keep their mouth yeah
yeah that the best it takes a long time
to heal up you know I ain't even heard
for a while those guys the guys that
because that I was hanging out with
woulda [ __ ] stop that dude into a
jelly don't beat up all old man they
don't know any better
they just women beat his ass up and
laughed it's the old man yet they didn't
have that kind of consciousness okay
can't you can't
can't [ __ ] project your [ __ ] sanity
onto others
ya know some people are [ __ ] crazy
yeah yeah they're [ __ ] they're know half
of them yeah yeah alright so hope you
guys are still keeping yourselves safe
and healthy out there have a good rest
of your Monday and we will talk to you
again tomorrow